ein wahlsonntag auf denen wir schauen
ein wahlsonntag mit einer landtagswahl
in schleswig-holstein also ganz im
norden der republik und das sind die
ersten bilder von dort aus schleswig
holstein
gerade in diesen momenten treffen die
zahlen ein die lager von cdu und spd
sehen sie hier unter einem reaktionen
sehen sie schon wer die wahl gewonnen
hat völlig überzeugend ist das ein war
kein wahlkampf für die cdu hier links im
bild die partei von ministerpräsident
ali günther sie kommt auf 43 prozent der
stimmen die spd erleidet heute eine
klatsche die erste klatsche für die spd
für die kanzlerpartei seit der
bundestagswahl nur 15 einhalb prozent
und sogar hinter den grünen die auf 17
prozent kommt die fdp bei sieben prozent
also ein überzeugender wahlabend für die
cdu für die märz partei das ist das was
sie heute über diesen wahlabend wissen
müssen schauen sie drauf einen
wahltriumph für die cdu an diesem tag
eine wahl klatschte das habe ich gerade
gesagt für die spd eine richtige
niederlage für die scholz partei die
erste wahl die der lage für olaf scholz
seit der bundestagswahl und eine neue
regierungskonstellation dort ganz im
norden daniel günther der
ministerpräsident cdu erkannt
weiterregieren kann sich jetzt aber
zwischen zwei partnern einen aussuchen
grüne oder fdp voraussichtlich würde
beides zum regieren reichen die grünen
heute mit einem überragenden
wahlergebnis auch die fdp könnte aber
möglicherweise noch als
regierungspartner für die cdu in frage
kommen dass also das was sie heute über
diesen wahlabend ganz oben im norden
wissen